welcome back everyone we are all about
giving back here at channel 8.
and today we are teaming up with the red
cross for giving day
and donating blood let's go back to john
langler and nate tannenbaum there at the
sahara west library with
morgan what's going on there hi guys
hey good afternoon good afternoon to you
alex as you mentioned we're here at the
sahara west library for
giving day with the red cross it is a
great day we'll be here till 4 30 this
afternoon you can go online to
redcross.org or call 1-800 red cross but
we have some special guests john that's
right redcrossblood.org if you want to
donate make sure you make an appointment
first
joined here by gina and gia gina and g
are here thank you very much for joining
us today
uh we're talking about blood donations
and the importance of it
your daughter is one reason that you
certainly advocate very
strongly for donating blood right so gia
has sickle cell disease
which is a disease that primarily
affects people of african-american
descent
so one of the things that helps keep
them healthy
and maintain their quality of life is
blood donation
gia has had nine blood donations so far
but each time she receives one
it makes her feel better immediately and
we can go home
as soon as the blood is all in and she
gets it so
it's very important for people to donate
blood because
kids like gia and other people benefit
greatly from those generous donations
you know so often we do stories about
the shortage of blood donations
whether it's in the valley or anywhere
else as a mother with with a child with
sickle cell
what goes through your mind when you
know that supplies are low and the
supplies are supplies that your daughter
needs
it's a scary feeling we're really
thankful every time we go to the
hospital and we don't have to wait that
long for her to be able to get her blood
that she needs when she's not feeling
well
but because there are shortages and
minorities are one population that has a
low donation rate so it's really
important for people
uh like gia with sickle cell disease to
get donations from
minority donors to help her out well
gina thank you very much
for joining us this morning and gia i
think your outfit is spectacular thank
you very much
wonder woman is here at the sahara west
library thank you very much
and again we're going to be here for a
giving day all day long at 8 news now
make an appointment donate blood if you
can alice go back to you in the studio
ah thank you guys so much and how cute
was chia
she's adorable and thank goodness she
gets through those blood donations so
please if you have time to give
today is a great day to do